I am McLaughlin being the returning
officer at the election for a member of
parliament for the Wallasey constituency
do hereby give notice that the number of
votes recorded for each candidate is as
follows
Kaplan Deborah Lindsay commonly known as
Kaplan Debbie UK Independence Party 1160
child's Paul Philip Liberal Democrats
772 Clough Lillian Isabel Margaret
commonly known as cloth lily Green Party
637 eagle Angela Labour Party 34,000
515 to
[Applause]
live see live see Andrew Julian commonly
known as Livesey Andy conservatives
11,000 232 the number of ballot papers
rejected was 77 and I do hereby declare
that Angela Eagle is Julie elected as a
member of parliament for Molly
[Applause]
well thank you I would firstly like to
thank the returning officer and we're
all Borough Council staff who have
helped to ensure that this election was
efficiently run encountered here tonight
I would also like to pay tribute to the
local police who following the appalling
events in Manchester and London
safeguarded our democratic process in
these times of uncertainty and tension I
think we should cut them
[Applause]
what one today in Wallasey were Labour's
values and the magnificent campaign my
volunteers helped me to fight now it
looks like the country has rejected
Teresa May and rejected her fear and
embrace jeremy corbyn's hope
authenticity and honesty
[Applause]
and I want to thank my agent Bridget
Priya for her incredible hard work and
her almost frightening levels of
organization I want to thank the
counselors and the hard-working
volunteers from all walks of life you've
given so much time to the labour
campaign here I couldn't have done it
without all of you as we campaigned I
was heartened and strengthened by the
small stories of how labour in
government locally and nationally makes
a real difference I can't thank enough
for her encouragement in a moment of
exhaustion the woman I spoke to during
one of our many doorstep canvassing
sessions I asked her if she would be
voting for me and she said of course I
am Angela 23 years ago I came to see you
with my baby daughter who'd just been
born with a hole in her heart you we
were living in a very damp flat and you
got me the move to this house she might
have died if you hadn't have helped us I
looked at a vibrant and smiling daughter
and at that moment all the slog and the
effort melted away it's for them that we
all worked so hard to get labour
candidates elected and I am so grateful
that they have repaid us without their
trust in this election but tonight
across the country it's clear that the
Tories are the losers I don't know about
you but honestly it couldn't have
happened to a nicer bunch a cruel
economically illiterate flip-flopping
incompetence defeating the Tories has
been my mission since I first joined the
Labour Party at 16 it was my mission
when I work for the health service trade
union cosy it was my mission when I
first sought election here in Wallasey
in 1992 defeating the Tory incumbent and
it remains my mission now
so tonight labour may not have a
majority but it truly is a victory for
our party and our country it's the
result of seven years of misery for too
many of my constituents who are all too
often on the receiving end of the casual
cruelty and the snuffed out life chances
that this Tory government delivered
alongside its unfairly distributed cuts
so why has this election defied the
pundits and pollsters predictions of
seven weeks ago ask my constituents this
is a Tory government that has an
appalling record on its self-defeating
austerity project which is strangled
investment and stalled growth on its
callous treatment of the poorest and
most vulnerable in society and I
regularly see its victims in tears in my
advice surgeries and let me be clear
this has been the worst most incompetent
most out-of-touch tory campaign in
living memory
we have a prime minister who called a
general election when she said she
wouldn't and then refused to turn up at
all throughout this campaign she avoided
scrutiny like a vampire avoids the
sunlight we have a chancellor who went
AWOL for the whole campaign and why
because they have nothing to boast about
on the economy the subject which has
dared not speak its name in this
election I want to thank and
congratulate our leader Jeremy Corbyn he
campaigns he campaigned positively to
communicate the Labour values that we
share but let us not be complacent our
movement must continue to broaden its
reach and open its ears to ensure that
those who are not convinced by as this
time will be next time and I pledge to
play my part any part my party should
ask of me we face an incredibly
important task in the next few years
negotiating a new future that protects
jobs investment growth security and our
influence in a rapidly changing world
this election was called specifically on
brexit Theresa May said again and again
that this was about brexit well the
people have spoken they have rejected
Theresa Mays approach to brexit childish
pointless hostility to Europe combined
with an uncritical attitude to Donald
Trump
the real coalition of chaos Liam Fox
David Davis and Boris Johnson who spent
the election acting the fool and
brawling with my
and group win in these circumstances
Parliament must revisit the negotiating
strategy and play a central role in
managing the brexit negotiations with a
genuine parliamentary vote on any final
deal anything less would be unacceptable
so we've got a lot to get on with and I
would like to thank the people of
Wallasey for allowing me to represent
you in the next parliament I promise to
you to give my effort my dedication and
my complete commitment in the month
ahead thank you
[Applause]